[Music]
I am Darius the great king the King of
Kings the king of Persia the king of the
provinces the son of Heist aspies the
grandson of Assamese the Achaemenid
[Music]
thus sayeth Darius the king my father is
his staffs peace the father of his dust
bees was Assamese the father of arse
amis was area Romney's the father of
area rameneh's was theis peace the
father of theis peace was a Khomeini's
on that account are we call the key
minute from antiquity are we descended
from antiquity had our race being Kings
ace of my race were Kings before me I am
the ninth in two lines have we been
Kings
by the grace of our Amma's de a my king
our Amma's de has ranted me the kingdom
these are the provinces which are
subject unto me and by the grace of era
Mazda became I king of them Persia
susiana Babylonia Assyria Arabia Egypt
the islands of the sea Sparta Ionia
Armenia Cappadocia Parthia during Jania
Aria Korres mia Bactria sogdiana
Gandhara Cydia SATA Hadiya Eric OSHA and
Makkah 23 lands in all these are the
provinces which are subject unto me by
the grace of our Mazda they became
subject unto me they brought tribute
unto me whatsoever commands have been
laid on them by me by night or by day
have been performed by them within these
lands whosoever was a friend him have I
surely protected whosoever was hostile
him have I utterly destroyed by the
grace of our Amma's de these lands have
conformed to my decrees even as it was
commanded unto them by me so was it done
our Mazda have granted unto me this
Empire our Mazda brought me help
until I gained this Empire by the grace
of our Mazda do I hold this Empire
you